the next generation of my hero academia
is a topic
you guys know i love to talk about and
today we're taking it one step further
than my previous videos
in this one we're conceptualizing how
the world of my hero could change
30 years after deku enrolled at ua this
includes topics such as the kids of ua
students and what their quirks would be
as well as how deku intends to find a
successor
and how the quirk singularity will
create new groups of villains
what i'm going to do is explain the
setting and then i'll explain deku and
his family
before getting into the plot summary
that i made up before we get into it
though there are two buttons you should
press
the first is the sub button as i think
we can reach 150k before the end of the
year
and the second is the join button by
hitting the join button you can become a
member of this channel for just two
dollars
and get access to my private discord
server where we talk about theories and
just other random stuff
hopefully i'll see some of you there but
without further ado let's get into the
video
back in the beginning of my here
academia around eighty 80
of the human population was born with
the quirk and in the future this
percentage would have only increased
perhaps to around 95 percent with more
and more quirks mixing together
hybrid abilities like todoroki's
half-hot half cold
have become much more common with one in
every four children
having this sort of power additionally
quirks themselves have become more
powerful
with random abilities like erie's rewind
quirk being seen more often
this would result in big changes to
society namely that the quirk
singularity doomsday theory
has now gained mainstream traction for
those that don't know
the quirk singularity theory was first
mentioned during season 4
and it claims that powers will get
stronger with each generation due to
quarks mixing together
until we reach a point where the
hardware of human bodies
can no longer handle the software of
quirks in 30 years time
the theory will be more widely accepted
due to the growing number of
overpowered quirks which of course will
result in more fear-mongering about the
future of humanity
this fear would be exploited by new
villain groups to gain members
and the villains i wanted to focus on
for this video is an organization i
decided to call reset
and you know that name is based on their
goals the group believes that the quote
singularity
is meant to restart humanity and create
a society where only powerful
individuals like them
should survive to achieve this utopia
even faster
they want to eradicate those with weak
bloodlines which first requires the
takedown of heroes so that no one can
stop them
basically they're fascists who want to
speed up natural selection
by destroying those they perceive as
weak and the main thing standing in
their way is the top heroes
reset have quietly been recruiting an
underground army with new members
only having the best of the best quirks
they have an intricate plan to get rid
of deku
and acquire the power of one for all and
it's already working better than
expected
when the day comes that they can obtain
that power then there will truly be no
one who can stop them
for now though let's move on to what's
going on with izuka midoriya
all those years after he enrolled at ua
as he promised at the beginning of the
series deku would have fulfilled his
goal by now of becoming the greatest
hero
but in doing so the secret of one for
all is now public knowledge
spoilers ahead for those of you who
don't read the manga but midoriya would
have unlocked all the quirks inside one
for all
making it impossible to hide the truth
about this power
it was foreshadowed this would happen
back in chapter 284
as there's only so many lies that deku
can tell to cover up his multiple quirks
at one point you just have to tell the
truth because the symbol of peace you
know to be the symbol
people have to trust you of course after
revealing the truth
his personal life would be changed
forever and mostly in a bad way
the primary reason why one fraud was a
secret in the first place
was because if people knew then it puts
the user and the people they care about
at risk this was proven to be correct as
villains from all over the world would
attempt to kidnap deku's relatives and
friends
every other week to you know to get him
to transfer one for all to them
as a consequence midoriya has had to
live an incredibly secretive personal
life
for a long time now and very few people
know of his relationship to ochako
uraraka
with the situation becoming harder to
keep a secret when she gave birth to
twins
15 years ago because harakoshi is a
massive star wars fan
i think it's likely that if deku ever
had kids they would definitely be twins
in star wars the chosen one anakin
skywalker
was a father to twins and in the world
of mahir academia
deku himself was referred to as the
chosen one
due to him being all my successor for
that reason i feel there would be a
parallel
and yeah deku would have a boy and a
girl in order to ensure the twin safety
from you know all these
crazy people who want to steal one for
from him midoriya would suggest
the kids take their mother's last name
to avoid any public connection to him
this would be one of many things
midoriya would do to try and give his
kids a normal childhood
but ultimately he'd fail at doing this
the twins would have
a relatively secluded upbringing and
were homeschooled wherever possible
and the only interaction they got with
other children was mainly just you know
kids of deku's close friends such as you
know todoroki
or i wanted to say bakago but i doubt he
would have children he just seems like
he'd be entirely focused on his hero
career over time
this has caused izuku to resent having
won for all on some level
as he believes that he made the wrong
decision in telling the truth to the
public
for the 15 years since the twins were
born midoriya has grappled back and
forth
with the idea of finding a successor and
on one occasion he considered passing it
to erie
however his innate urge to save people
always overruled
and he never felt truly ready to give up
the power until now
before i get into why deku is ready to
give it up let me explain deku's kids
and what their quirks are
for those of you who haven't seen my
specific video on this original
character
i decided to name deku's first child
nori uraraka
and this was a reference to almight
whose real name was of course
toshinoriyagi it's pretty much
inevitable that deku would name one of
his kids
after his mentor and in fact he might
even go further than that
and name all his kids after his mentor
in some way who knows
nori is the eldest child of deku and
achako as she was born 15 minutes before
her twin brother
her quirk is called gravity shift as it
allows her to pull things towards her
and then when she makes contact
gravity will shift in some way for
example she could choose to make someone
float upon touching them
or she could do the opposite and turn up
gravity so they slam into the ground
currently the main drawback is that she
can't make anything float if it's above
four tons
while she respects her parents her goal
in life was never to become a hero
that being said she still practices with
her quirk in her spare time
but it's mainly so she doesn't fall
behind her brother
the name of her brother is aikito
uroraka and i consider
him to be very interesting like many
characters such as toga for example
aikido's personality is affected by the
nature of his quirk
but we'll get to that after i explain
his abilities the name of akito's quirk
is light ray
and it allows him to disorient enemies
with viciously bright rays of light
that he emits from his fingertips as you
would expect
the light rays travel from his
fingertips at light speed
meaning that if he gets an accurate shot
his opponent literally has
no way to avoid it also if he
concentrates all his fingers into a
single beam
then the heat can get quite intense and
may even start a fire
light ray is an accumulation type quirk
in the same spirit as
fat absorption or one for all basically
his body stores light whenever he goes
about his daily life
and then when he's ready to release it
the rays can be blindingly bright
it works from long range and is a
perfect support type quirk
as he can confuse enemies from a safe
distance while other heroes jump in to
take advantage
this brings us to why i think he's quite
interesting and there are a few reasons
here
number one aikido idolizes his father in
the same way that deku once idolized
almai
but the twist is that because he's
deku's son he feels an intense pressure
to replicate his dad's success
as the child of the number one hero
akito feels that he'll one day need to
live up to his father's reputation
especially as his sister has never cared
about becoming a pro hero
in a nutshell he wants the legacy of his
favorite heroes
father to continue with him he never
considered his light rayquark to be
anything special
so he trains his body as a vessel in the
hope that his father will one day
acknowledge him
when it's time to find a successor now
just before we move on remember earlier
i said that aikido's personality
was affected by the nature of his quirk
whilst he's in natural light
he's a brave friendly and optimistic
person much like his father in a way
on the flip side if he doesn't have
enough light stored inside him
and if there's little sunlight outside
then it's possible his thoughts may
gravitate
towards a dark place but most of the
time you know that doesn't trickle down
into his everyday actions okay
so with that explained we are finally
ready to talk about the plot summary
which will include more details about
the villains and also the other kids of
ua students
to start with i think it's only right
that a sequel series like this should
begin with deku himself
as he walks through the halls of ua as a
middle-aged hero
he'd be roughly the same age as what
endeavour is in the present series
and i imagine that current ua students
would probably collapse with excitement
just at the sight of him after signing
autographs and doing all that jazz
deku would walk directly into the
principal's office to have a chat
at this time the principle would be
tenueda as from day one of this series
it seemed like tenure had his own ideas
for how ua should be doing things under
his leadership the school would have
made big changes already
with the most significant being the
addition of two new hero classes
so now you have class 1a 1b 1c and 1d
they're all hero core students with
villain quirks becoming stronger than
ever
edi would probably feel the need to
raise more heroes
to a ua standard to help combat the
evolving threats
as deku and his friend talk the
conversation would divert to the reason
deku arranged this meeting
which is to tell the principal that he's
finally looking for a long-term
successor
as i explained earlier midoriya had been
toying with this idea ever since his
kids were born
but it was only after he failed to stop
the death of a pro hero quite recently
that he decided that more people could
be saved if he passed on one for all
upon hearing this tenure would
immediately whip out a 50-page binder
full of candidates that he considers
worthy of one for all which would both
freak out
and impress deku at the same time
midoriya would explain that while he
trusts tenure's judgment
he needs to have an open mind and make
the decision based on his own instincts
therefore deku's proposal is to join the
ua teaching staff part-time
in the new school year and basically
he'll observe some of the first-year
students as the year progresses
eventually he'll select a few elite
candidates to take with him on a work
study
and after that he'll let the kids know
about his true motivation to find a
successor
this process will give him a really
clear idea of who is both physically and
mentally capable of succeeding him
and taking this quirk for the next
generation when we compare this to all
might you know i mean
he essentially picked a random kid he
just met that day
trained him physically for 10 months and
then made him use one for all
on the same day he got it without any
real guidance on how to use the quirk
the results did pay off i guess but it
was a very risky strategy
by contrast deku is being much more
careful but still
fair now in the back of midoriya's mind
he'd long suspected
that akito wanted to be the next user of
one for all
he noticed how his son would
relentlessly train his body
and his motivation to become a hero
reminded deku of a younger version of
himself
deku never wanted either of his children
to have one for all
as it was something that would just
continue to affect their way of life
additionally as omai implied deku isn't
the type of person who's a fan of this
kind of favoritism
so you know he wouldn't want to give it
to his kids just because they're his
kids
rather he'd want to give it to someone
who is worthy of being the next user
this is partly why his proposal to
tenure is perfect
if akito can pass the ua entrance exam
in a few months
and then prove himself worthy above all
the other first years
then yes deku would reluctantly give the
quote to his son
on the other hand if another student was
to outperform akito you know in terms of
the criteria for getting one for all
then at least midoriya was still fair to
his son and gave him a chance
midoriya hopes that if he was to give it
to someone else that akito wouldn't
resent him for it
anyway we should switch over to our two
main characters who as you've probably
guessed are akito
and nori at the beginning of the story
they'd be 14 years old
with aikito having hopes of passing the
upcoming
ue entrance exam the exam usually takes
place in february
so for argument's sake let's just say
that the events right now
are happening in november like we
already established
there are more spaces on the hero course
than ever before
and akita believes that if he gets into
ua then he's one step closer on his
journey to receiving
one for all the scene could open with
him intensely training in the backyard
of their secluded home
this training is occurring at the same
time that deku is meeting with tenure
so right now the only people in the
world who even know midori is looking
for a successor
is ochako which is his wife tenure and
an unknown character who we'll get to
later whilst akito is working hard for
the ua
exam nori has been pretty much chilling
for the most part
as she knows she's probably just gonna
go to a regular high school
for the first time in their lives the
privacy that has kind of shrouded their
existence up until this point is finally
going away
and they are allowed obviously to attend
these public schools where they'll be
seen
by a lot of people and you know some
people may suspect that they are deku's
children i mean
they they do bear a resemblance to him
very heavily
but yeah that's just a risk they're
going to take at this stage in their
lives
what i imagined is that during this
intense training that aikito is doing
you know whilst deku's out the house
some kind of accident or
incident would occur that would put
akito in serious danger
maybe villains had finally found them
and were attacking the house
or maybe akita just got in some sort of
training accident but just know it has
to be something where nori tries to save
him with gravity shift
and just can't do it in such a life or
death situation
all sorts of emotions would be racing
through her mind and it would cause her
to briefly tap in
to an unknown power this power would
have been building inside her quietly
since the day she was born
and to save her brother in this
situation she would unleash it with its
full
force imagine a long-range attack like
air force or air cannon
it's basically something equivalent to
that which could save her brother
at that moment the idea is that nori has
a hybrid quirk like todoroki
that even she didn't know about gravity
shift is one half of this hybrid
and this other unknown power is the
other half
because one thrall is ingrained into
deku's dna
a part of it was passed down to nori in
nori's case she wouldn't have
the one for all but it'd be something
that was derived from it
and started from zero it's been building
up in power ever since she was a child
and she never knew it was there because
like i said it started out as nothing
and so it's taken a long time to reach
this level of strength
maybe it's just the stockpile quirk or
maybe it maybe it could be transferred
as well
let me know what you think is more
realistic down below but either way it
is not
the one for all it is just you know
something that's derived from it
the ramifications of this are huge
midoriya wasn't there when the incident
occurred
so he'd spend the next couple months
trying to figure out what happened
and bring this power out again with the
risk that nori doesn't have control over
this mysterious power
it's possible that she could cause an
accident to occur that would endanger
people
so as responsible parents deku and
ochako decided that she had to go to ua
as well
only with a proper quirk education can
you avoid being a danger to society when
you when you don't even have control
over your power
and with midoriya now watching over the
first year students anyway
he could keep a personal eye on her
progress throughout these months when
deku was trying to bring out nori's
power
akito would start to feel neglected and
with it still being the winter months
his darker thoughts would again start to
come to the forefront
we see him grapple between different
feelings of gratitude for his sister for
saving his life
but also confusion at how exactly she
saved him
and what that power is also the fact
that she's now applying to ua which was
always
always his dream is now kind of rubbing
him the wrong way
at this moment you can say his
personality is beginning to shift
from one that was more like deku to i
guess a more
selfish i guess almost like baka go in a
way
in that he doesn't want doesn't want
other people to win
over the next arc you see the difference
between the sibling's natural talent
as nori would pass the ua entrance exam
with ease although still not able to use
her one frau style power
whereas akito would struggle under the
weight of his insecurity
and he would barely pass but bearing in
mind that he's been training for this
for a long time much longer than his
sister
so it would just kind of you know serve
to show you the gap of natural talent
between these two
obviously deku and achako would be
incredibly proud of both their kids
as this would be a big moment for the
family with nori joining class 1a and
akito joining class 1d
deku finally reveals to them that he
will also be joining ua as a teacher
on a part-time basis up till now he
hadn't actually told them
as he was waiting to see if they would
get into ua and also
if you look at most of the current ua
staff they're all active
current heroes right and so deku
wouldn't really need to
explain himself he wouldn't need to tell
him the truth especially as he needs to
see how all the students act
naturally as the kids move into their
dorms nori would become reacquainted
with seki todoroki
who is the youngest of three children in
the todoroki family
like his father he has a hybrid quirk
and his left side is able to produce
these
intense white flames that can turn blue
when he decides to get serious
by contrast the right side of his body
can convert the
lipids in his body into literally any
non-living thing
using these abilities in tandem seki is
the ultimate spear and shield
as he can create objects that amplify
his flames
or he can just change his strategy
completely
seki has lofty ambitions and wants to
travel abroad to be a hero in tons of
different countries before returning to
japan
in his adulthood his older brother would
also be at uae
as a third year hero corps student and
his sister would already be a sidekick
at the shoto hero agency seki and nori
were actually childhood friends back in
the day
so he already knows that nori is the
secret love child of deku and ochako
meanwhile in the dorms of class 1d akito
would
be pretty reclusive on his first day and
wouldn't really mingle too much with his
new classmates
despite achieving his goal of getting
into ua he feels that it's been
overshadowed by many unexplained events
over the past few months
he's very suspicious of his dad's true
motives about joining ua
and the incident with his sister still
plays on his mind he's still not sure
what exactly happened the fact she
scored higher than him in the entrance
exam
despite him training consistently for a
long time it kind of put him in a
fragile state of mind
which is potentially where the villains
could take advantage of him
now speaking of the bad guys i should
probably explain a little bit their
intricate plan that i referenced earlier
in the video
this plan of course is to acquire one
for all and in the process
weaken the symbol of peace and
strengthen the villain organization
you remember how i said they've been
quietly recruiting an army of powerful
quirk users
and the son of hitoshi shinzo is at the
core of this
it goes without saying that at the best
hero high school you're likely to find
the best quirks
and for years reset has had an insider
inside ue
who has been recruiting a handful of
students they felt would align with
their cause
five years ago the son of shinzo who i
decided to call ichiro
was the first student to be recruited by
the villains due to the nature of his
quirk
ichiro's power is called inception and
he can plant an idea in someone's head
as long as they say something to him the
idea will grow
naturally inside that person's mind as
if they were the ones who thought of it
first
which will lead to the person going down
a path that they likely would not have
chosen for themselves
however the idea planted has to be
somewhat realistic
otherwise it won't work ichiro would go
on to graduate
and become sort of a double agent as he
was working as a psychic for his father
whilst also being given missions by
reset to recruit certain heroes
in the present day a large but currently
unknown number of heroes across japan
are converted believers of reset's
ideology and literally could go order 66
at any moment
despite that the main thing stopping the
villains from launching their attack
is the existence of the number one hero
who just has a ridiculous level of power
even for a former shonen protagonist
over the years
many of reset's most overpowered
villains were defeated by deku with ease
and a new strategy had to be formed the
secret leader of the villains could
maybe defeat deku but if he was to
reveal himself and then lose
everything would be over i imagine that
as a last resort
ichiro would be tasked to try and get
close to midoriya and convince him to
pass the power to someone they could
manipulate
because of the limitations of the
inception quirk ichiro can't make deku
give it to anyone
instead the most realistic option from
an outsider perspective
would be to ask deku to give it to a
younger person who is worthy of
inheriting it
in the same way that all might gave it
to deku when he was about 14.
if ichiro could accomplish this then all
they would need to do is either recruit
a new young person who they can you know
put on a pedestal and make deku believe
is worthy of inheriting the power
or they could just do the same process
but with someone who's already part of
the organization
it was a good idea but isro getting
close to the top hero proved
way harder than expected and he just
couldn't get that access
back in the day even the top two heroes
endeavour and all might
went 10 years without seeing each other
so you know it's not that easy getting a
meeting with the top hero
growing frustrated the leader of reset
would have organized an attack against
the shinzo agency
without telling ichiro first the aim of
this plan was to draw out deku
and essentially get deku to be in a
location where each row would definitely
be
in addition the villain was instructed
to kill literally everyone except ichiro
so the likelihood of dekuen and ichiro
interacting
was very high an attack on an actual
hero agency is something we've never
seen before in my hero
so i imagine it would be of a
significant scale to draw out the number
one hero
of course deku being deku he would
respond to something like this and he
definitely would show
up and as he arrived i imagine that when
deku gets there
he literally sees shinzo being killed
before his eyes
he quickly dealt with the villain and
began to search for survivors
with ichiro being the only one alive as
planned
naturally the boy was filled with
unimaginable anger and confusion
as he was unsure whether this was a
truly random villain attack
or if it was some kind of message from
the leader of reset
as his head was scrambling itra would be
approached by a sunken looking deku
who offered his condolences the number
one would express how he should have
been there quicker
and how he did everything in his power
to stop this from happening
while ichiro was still unsure about who
was responsible for the attack
he acknowledged that in this situation
with midoriya standing in front of him
this was maybe his only chance to use
inception on the top hero
i'd imagine that at this part you'd see
ichiro looking up at deku with his eyes
wide open followed by a flash forward
the flash forward would take us back to
the principal's office
and this is the moment when deku was
talking to tenure about the reasons he
needs to find a successor
the implication of doing this flash
forward at this moment would be clear
but for those who don't get it deku just
got inceptioned
the beauty of ichiro's quirk is that if
an idea is even remotely realistic for
that person
it will cling on to all other relevant
ideas and just become something that
deku believes he thought of himself
ichiro planted the idea that a young and
fresher hero
would have saved hitoshi's life and
suggested that midoriya choose a
successor
from one of the new ua students in the
upcoming year
this concept would be planted in deku's
mind and would combine with his real
feelings about his desire to
save more people his desire to not be
unfair to akito
and his long-standing anxiety about
finding a successor to one for all
ichiro didn't know that deku had a son
or anything like that
but he did know for a fact that in that
moment deku regretted not being able to
save shinzo
and so he preyed on that insecurity
instead because midoriya was tricked
now any new ua recruit has a chance of
inheriting one for all
and of course reset had months to
prepare an ideal candidate
who passed the uh entrance exam and is
now among the first years
we already knew there was a teacher at
ua working for reset
which is why ichiro and other students
join the organization
in the first place that teacher whoever
they may be
can manipulate situations to put their
candidate in a good light
and ensure that the undercover student
acquires one for all
but anyway if you've made it this far
then thank you for watching the video
and uh yeah i hope you enjoyed the the
original characters and the new quirks
and the basis of this plot which i've
laid out here feel free to expand on any
of my ideas
and sub to the channel as i think we can
reach 150k
before the end of the year until the
next one peace out